this is carpet diem and actually had a
yo get it this is I think I'm gonna
shock myself at some point and then
we'll switch bodies right it's just that
this is Garbett damage I had our own
we're little moment here when I was
looking up on the phone with the what
the code was at the end it actually I
said the code is but who stole the
capers or who took the capers and
literally as I looked it up differences
but who took the capers as I got you
were way more impressed with that than I
was cuz he just stared at this one he
just went whoa it's just a weird like in
the moment it's it's weird
of course it's just a big coincidence um
so this episode this is a body switch
episode you've seen this in a lot of
movies and cartoon shows and stuff like
that but like everything in gravity
falls they do it right I gotta be honest
I love body switch episodes they for
some reason they always make me laugh
maybe I'm just very simple and I like
hearing a different voice come on bu or
a woman born in a man's body they be
hearing they do well after uh after the
next review people get me say that
already the priory saying it cuz I've
liked it been and dragged a billion
times you know technically you're an icy
jolly got you dressed like me yeah I was
gonna say but that's cuz she's awesome
um so it's an episode where they find an
extra room uh dipper is kind of looking
for his own space because maples having
a slumber party and hanging out with her
friends more so they discovered the
secret room that Stan seems very
resistant werewolves bare chest Asst
I'll romance novel ever and the thirty
sequels that follow yeah and dipper
really wants the room and then Mabel
really wants the room kind of outta
spite and they discovered this carpet in
there I love this idea you rub against
the carp and the static electricity if
you touch someone switches minds uh
which i think is such a fun idea i me
that's such an inventive way to do that
so is that the same room grunkle Stan
went into at the beginning of no that's
behind a vending machine this was behind
the shell
there's some interesting stuff I was
noticing this time around I'll bring it
up one thing that was driving me nuts on
the calendar July 4th was circled and
I'll figure out why well we'll get to
that too um I don't have an answer but
we will yes we know I actually I was
noticing a lot of stuff in this episode
like I did not pick up the first time um
so they're going back and forth arguing
they're pretending to be the other
they're trying to piss off Stan because
all right this is we're not I'm out of
here
it's the more they do that the more he's
more likely to give the key to the other
person which is what they want um and of
course being each other's bodies they
understand each other more
Zuse uh soos gets switched with a pig
with waddles somehow wins the heart of
this woman which I'm still wondering how
that happened she just obviously crazy
woman yes I will marry you but what I
don't
okay um and actually Zeus as a pig I
kind of wish they kept him as the pig
because I found him even more hilarious
as a pig don't win hurl about the cliche
when when pigs ooze was running around I
kind of said there was like would
anybody have noticed no I will ask and
didn't I love it when Wendy comes in it
just sees him like every day of uhud she
backs off yeah just come back later and
then it's a negotiating with Stan just
putting the hand I was facing home
so a bench on a switchback understand
each other I really like the moment
where they're about to go sleep in their
separate rooms and they say good night
to each other but the others not there
um
so finally of course they decide to go
back into the sharing the room again it
kind of like the Halloween episode could
you know the guy had to split up in two
different rooms but it's like they don't
need to yet which I like I mean that
that's fine um the ending was very
heartwarming yeah so um fan fiction
writers shut up
stan is outside but so why am I even
outside casually getting odd hit me in
the head right in the head yeah I did
that's just why am I even outside this
late at night
all right so a funny episode I mean like
I said I like the I like episodes where
the mind switch and stuff
couple figure those first of all the
boys world stuff is all over the place
they're going to show up in the next
episode this boyband
uh but yeah okay the calendar now that
was a July 4th it was night it was 1982
- yeah um Stan seemed very resistant to
that room and something that's
interesting I think it brought us up
before the triangle uh the symbol the
triangle keeps popping up sometimes
there's an eye in the middle you see it
at the beginning that it wasn't in this
room except for one part where there's a
prism that's like the I think it was
just referencing dark side of the mood
the the Pink Floyd think there's only a
triangle it has a little rainbow on the
side yeah I'm also wondering like does
that come to play with a banana boat for
1982 yeah so but it's again that
triangle symbol doesn't seem to be in
the room except for that one bit which
is interesting um very interesting that
there's a picture of a there's a picture
of a woman uh in the back on that wall
you know again kind of an older notice
ed - yeah if I had to guess um if I had
to guess I would say this is a room Stan
knows what it is maybe he thought it
wouldn't be a shelter I mean but he he I
think he had this room set aside for
something you know either someone or
something cuz the carpet was in the -
experiment 78 and either something
happened or he had his heart broken
there or something like experiment 78
stands for the year cuz of this shag
carpeting and that was very 70s yeah
there's a lot to had the arrows on there
- that could be cat seventies I'm
already thinking about um but yes that's
my gun we missed the time-traveling dude
so sure okay okay I'm not perfect all
right I'm not perfect um and this is
your second time watching it I do Mara
there's an episode that does talk about
like a past girlfriend staying here but
I can't remember if it connects students
so it's a possibility but yeah my it's
fancy so resistant to it I'm really
thinking that has something to do with
it something on the mast
sorry let me just want to say uh okay I
thought you were gonna be done uh and
the event last two things I know is
actually I'm gonna do with the room but
they're just funny uh there was a code
in the book when he was
Elling dipper Mabel about the birds and
the bees there was a code at the bottom
of the book uh but I'm too lazy to
figure it out so somebody else wants to
that is actually worse to talk about
that may have been my favorite scene
it's like I think it's time we had a
discussion about the birds and the bees
and just Mabel and dipper x' buddy oh
yeah and my childhood yeah those my
favorite they react to justice goodbye
childhood you know what I would have
liked though okay they throw it away for
everyone this is the pituitary gland it
may be small but it's got big guy big
glanced and the was the the little tag
line in the bottom every detail about
your body explained in horrifying detail
why am i so sweaty well and what I love
to it that not only is Mabel learning
about sex but she's learning about it
through like the boy body so cuz we say
now your penis is whoa
but what no what what I thought was a
missed opportunity was that because
while that's going on dipper his Mabel
is hearing this romance novel that's you
know for whatever like older audiences I
would have liked if he weren't about sex
through that Oh God
well I guess maybe I you you could argue
it but I was only I mean think about
those romance
they said age-inappropriate yeah I mean
it's but he was more like I think the
line they had was okay that's over
now for the sequels oh it's like he I
felt well been funnier if he also had
the line goodbye childhood after they
were done writing that book that were
vindicated that like he was told this
yeah hey I guess um so but they had
another joke going where they all shout
no it's like fair enough you I get this
our joke going been a bit funnier um and
the only thing I notice in terms of a
funny little add-on is that once uh
Mabel as dipper has the room she's
putting on the sign no boys and crosses
off and puts no girls across it often
puts boys question bar like she's
actually but that is a great point
because he calls what happened he
referred to himself as Mabel or refer
yet he forgot what he was happened to me
as I was watching it I'm like wait who's
who again I totally forgot like a kg
would forget yeah I like that they
themselves forget who they are
as it was happening me as I was watching
the show I'm like that's right their
bodies are switched so that's really
maple that's really uh um so yeah I let
a part of me kind of almost wanted them
to be in different rooms at the end
because they say at the end what are you
gonna do in that extra room oh I don't
know something or other I almost love
liked a little bit more if they did
separate but it was still like like you
said they would have some lumper parties
and visited stuff that they would still
keep that space good this is gonna
happen they are gonna grow up it was her
way now true there's a second season
yeah true Mississippi you know we start
with the summer we one where it's like
yeah we don't have to quite do this yeah
we can still remain children stuff but
it's like you're gonna get older I mean
it is part of it and I think that is a
big part of my identities you want your
space um but I guess they are still kids
I don't know Oh having braces sucks
you're so sweaty and awkward um I love
when he's in her body he looks in there
goes Oh runs away that you come back
again oh oh their first reactions were
gray and cowering in the corner who do
you think the toilet and everything um
so yeah good episode yeah I thought was
really funny um like I'm just a sucker
for these kinds of episode anytime it's
like a body switch of Harvey kind of
groans but for me it's like wait look I
like these I like this possibility I
like the ideas I can do with it and no I
definitely really need it laughs so
enjoying yourself I am literally
enjoying yourself I can make my nose
glow I think you're becoming Mabel
wearing that hey I can kind of see
through my finger I can see through that
one too
you took this fun little enjoyable thing
and made it into wrong just like twin
says and dipper goes to Taco Bell I
didn't create twincest and I didn't
create dipper goes to tell you mentioned
it you encouraged it you brought it into
this place of good share the suffering
by the way you still need to see that I
still haven't